Automobiles, 1770, Cugnot's Trolley, 1828, Gurney's Tugboat, 1833, Hancock's Enterprise, 1859, Ricketts Boiler, 1875, Bullies Dependable, 1894, Leviser's Panhardt.
Don't move anymore. That's it. Let's have the next one, please.
And now, gentlemen, are you ready?
Yes.
Give us the signal. We're all ready.
No. One moment. Just one, please.
Don't move anymore.
A photo of me, too.
1994 Paris Rouen, the first automobile race and so gentlemen you will all agree
This is not actually a race. It's dependability and endurance that is important. You have eight hours to do a hundred and twenty six
No one can do it in that time
Only animal traction was not allowed and so there were cars with levers with pendulums hydraulic motors
compressed air and compressed water
There were also electromagnetic vehicles,
mined with liquids, weights and gas, and many others.
But none of them were able to pass the preliminaries,
that is to go for 50 kilometers.
Well, sir, I bet we show them.
Faster!
Oh, they're mad.
They must be doing 20 kilometers an hour.
Hey, get up there!
One year later, in June 1895,
the Bordeaux-Paris rally would open the era of car racing.
This time, the ground covered was 1,200 kilometers.
Get set, and go.
They're catching up with the Benz.
It's the Peugeot No. 8, and where is me? Did it pass us? Oh, wow.
Well, that's one less.
Stick to it.
At least it was close.
Au revoir, monsieur.
And at Goulet's latest thing.
Look at that, that means only one.
Good luck.
Well, it's four hours we've been driving, but did he on his way out in front?
Is there someone behind us?
No, it's fine.
The flyer are doing at least 30.
I'll lead at this race. They're never going to catch up with us.
Say, Chief, would you like to play a joke on them?
Well, why not?
This, that's a good joke, no?
You go straight.
I'm going to complain to the prefect about the state of this road.
It's scandalous.
This won't be the last deal here for me.
But that Bordeaux is much bigger.
It's navigating.
Five minutes, you just keep it up.
You bet, Chief, it's in the bag.
Do you see what I see?
Oh, no, I'm going crazy.
Five minutes, Chief.
Who's going to win? Steam, more powerful, but more fragile than petroleum. Petroleum. In 1859, a certain Drake found some petroleum in Pennsylvania, which incited a certain Rockefeller to found a certain company, Standard Oil. And a young American mechanic tinkers around and builds a car that runs by gas and can't get through the door. His name was Henry Ford.
Ah, we've arrived in Bordeaux. Turn around. Right away.
See what I see?
Have you repaired a jet? My goodness.
Are you good for nothing?
Yes, sir.
And it's the triumphant arrival of the winners.
1900. Europe has 400 million inhabitants.
Asia, 900 million.
America, 150 million.
Africa, 120 million.
White power dominates the world, except for Japan.
The slave trade had been a source of considerable revenue in the past.
Now, it was a small-time business.
During the time of colonization, things were done on a larger scale.
Populations and all their resources were to be exploited.
We can't leave half the globe to ignorant people, said the economist Leroy Boyeux.
It's our domination of these wretched people that will assure them peace and prosperity.
Yes, the Anglo-Saxon race is the greatest ruling race that the world has ever known,
said Joseph Chamberlain, a British statesman.
A treaty in Berlin set up the rules of the game.
Europe had sunk her teeth into Asia.
She had claimed 90% of Africa.
Try a game?
Sure.
It works.
1900, in France, the elections gave the majority rule to the Republicans.
The Louis Renault workshop had all of two workers.
It should go now.
Well, yes, it should go now.
Yeah, yeah.
Freud was into dreams, Max Planck the quantum theory, Pavlov conditioned reflexes, Rutherford the structure of atoms, and Einstein's relativity.
Bravo, my friend, it's turning like a sewing machine.
Congratulations.
So, Pierrette, you'll be ready soon?
Yes, sir.
Before the afternoon.
Madame saw some nice things.
Adorable Sherman, a collection of original.
Oh, can we walk a bit?
If you want, there's no real hurry.
Look at that picture, not bad, huh?
It's signed Picasso, it's a new style.
It's not about to become famous.
Sure, then.
Yes, but it's more tiring.
1900, the first female lawyer is sworn in.
And for some time now, women doctors are practicing.
Girls are admitted to colleges.
If there are several courageous female students at the Sorbonne,
it wasn't until 1908 that there would be a female professor, Marie Curie.
Train?
Yes, and it would be called the Metropolitan.
Brown. That I couldn't pick up next.
Weather is splendid.
And so what is...
Oh, please, can we all go canoeing?
It's too crowded.
Make up your minds.
Maestro will have a good idea.
Follow me.
Oh, let's stop. I'm worn out.
Ah, come on. It's Sunday. We should have fun.
Well, I'll stay here. This is just fine.
Come see this sign here.
It's cinematography.
I've heard that you see all kinds of great things and sitting on a chair.
That would just suit me fine.
Come on.
The impoverished peasants left for the cities, looking for easier work that paid better.
They found overpopulation, tenements, crowded suburbs bursting at the seams.
Between 1850 and 1914, the population of Europe will double itself.
In the cities, it will be multiplied by five, if not more.
The worker will emerge as a new social species whose only benefit is work.
He would have to defend that.
Socialism, syndicalism were growing.
In spite of Pope Pius X's address, the workers of the world didn't want to wait for a better one.
What modern times predicted.
Madame, you sure?
Is that you, Pierrette?
Don't shout like that. Goodness, I'm not stone deaf.
Now look, it's crazy to call here. I've got a job here.
What did you say?
It's not possible. It looks like we had a visit from Picasso.
That's exactly it.
Are you ready, stone girls?
The weekend break was established and everyone enjoyed it.
Now you're in for a surprise. How'd you like to go to the sea?
Do you see that big buggy? I'm gonna pass it.
I'm gonna be who wants to pass this, boss. Look.
Is he deaf or is he stubborn?
Hey, you! You move over, dummy! What kind of a night is he anyway?
Teach him some manners. You watch, menace.
Top turn. What are you doing?
Uh, cleaning.
Don't you think that's a strange way to clean up?
Oh, no, no. You can go on through. Go on through.
Uh, you wait now. I'm gonna put you in your place and once and for all...
Mama!
Something wrong here.
No, I'm gonna box your ears now.
Uh, one moment if you please.
I'm waiting.
But two. But two. But two.
Underworld!
After Russia's defeat, the Japanese annexed Korea.
These conquests are out of the death knell for European supremacy in the Far East.
Don't move anymore.
Developer works like a charm.
There's a good resemblance. Well, here's your change, madam.
I was a young girl.
And often, I'd come here to have a look.
What is it, mom?
Well, I think it's a man. Yes, you see his mustache?
Well, that man isn't too pretty. He's awful.
It is true. He's a bit strange.
Come on, my sweet. If you're good, you'll get something nice.
What is it?
Quite a crow.
I bet you that it's a toy you have.
Mm-mm.
Is it a candy?
Is it?
Get into it, you'll see what.
What is it?
It's not tempting.
This is called a banana.
It's quite good, so try it.
It comes from a warm country with palm trees and black men.
You know, a lot of little boys have never tasted a banana.
Oh, oh, mmm.
The Entente Cordiale was answered by the Triple Entente.
The ponds were set up as mobilization proceeded.
And what?
The Eiffel Tower?
You've gotten me there.
I don't know.
Must manufacture these things right away.
It's urgent.
Ah, there you are.
Now tell your papa what you've done, sweetheart.
Well, I ate a banana, and it wasn't very good, but then I love my dad and mom.
Ah, now that's the way to talk, my good boy.
We must always be good and love our papa and our mama, that's true.
And be happy, my children, but make it fast, because as you know, happiness doesn't last too long.
In vain, De Tolstoy, Dostoyevsky, Verlaine, Rimbaud, Ibsen, Jornson, and Strindberg cry out against a heartless universe.
Who listened to?
Military powers wanted to put it apart.
France's need to strike back.
Pan-Germanism, Pan-Slavism aroused the people.
This time is perfect.
I know that thing will never work.
That's how it is you too pick.
Well, and this won't work either?
Hehehehe
Evidently it won't work.
What else you have there?
Huh?
Very well gentlemen, I understand.
He's not a very patient.
Wah!
He he he he.
This will really be good. I hope somebody remembered the mustard.
All the work!
Ah!
He he he.
He he he he.
Hey, stop it, you're tickling me here!
Compared to the economic crisis, war was welcome.
It would put an end to dissension.
Take the uniforms out of mouth balls.
Hurry, let's get out of the rain.
Geopolitician Bernardi declared just before 1914,
war is not only a biological necessity,
in some cases, it is also a moral obligation,
an indispensable factor of civilization.
It's also true that the general is Prussian.
And so, war, mankind's folly.
Responsible leaders, hesitant diplomats,
warmongering generals,
and the world is headed for the greatest cataclysm of its history.
Nature had claimed that all men were not equal,
The super race had power over all.
Gobineau in France, Chamberlain in England, followed in his footsteps.
Who wasn't of the super race?
The Germans made a surprise attack on Belgium.
In no time, they were only 24 kilometers from Paris.
But there was a counterattack at the Marne, and a mobilized front.
Seas of the Marne!
They settled into trench warfare.
All fronts, attack and counterattack, on star.
Attack!
Can't you fight?
Come on!
Well darling, I would propose.
And what's the exact weight of your weapon?
Around 300 tons.
But when fully charged...
But it's a mere feather.
But I can do better.
Would you look at the Global Trotter?
38 meters long, 22 wide, an invincible fortress.
Well, sir?
Very well, I understand.
But don't go yet.
This thing will protect the ground artillery.
I call this a tank or armored car.
Yes, it seems like a fine idea.
And so it will do.
1917 was the year that the United States
entered the war and when russia defected in the revolution thank you gentlemen and now here's my
latest invention like this it's a helmet it can also be used as a sink it's a pot as a shovel and
now a propeller driven vehicle and it runs on absolutely all terrains it runs even when there's
not a bit of terrain at all all right my latest my very latest discovery a machine gun that fires
in between the blades as they turn yeah i'm serious 1918 the german offensive is followed
by the Allied counterattack.
En avant!
November the 11th, 1918, an Allied victory.
25 million dead, as many wounded and disabled.
How to measure the suffering?
What was it for?
Was it to obtain universal peace for all time to come?
The Kaiser abdicates, flees after bewailing
I never thought it would be like that.
And so, who had wanted that?
Who could have imagined that?
Let's look at Russia again, where history was being made.
1905, the first riots in Russia.
The defeat of Port Arthur by the Japanese.
The Tsar made a few concessions.
Authorized to Parliament, Palm was restored so he lost no time in going back to his old ways
Poor little child. Probably freezing. Yes, at least get him some bread.
In 1717, the war desired by the Tsar was raging. A modern war for which Russia was ill-prepared.
No munitions, no officers, no food. More than seven million men are disabled.
Couldn't go home now, my. Your mother will stand.
In the city's famine strikes. The women can no longer watch their families perish.
Our children need you.
Man comes into this course of history.
Liberty reserved only to members of the government, members of the party, is not liberty.
Liberty has always been liberty of thought.
Liberty becomes a privilege that no longer exists.
So said Rosa Luxemburg, only it turned out.